us they coming to the mic talking about
the food they hate talking about the
food they like two Fool's gonna fight
but only one food can be right hello
taste buddies this is the taste bud
podcast and welcome to t-a-s-t-e butts
which I forgot to do in the Bobby Kelly
episode but uh Chota Rosa is uh not in
today and so we have our friend Ian
Finance our good friend and hysterical
comedian you have not been on taste buds
yet I have not but you have it on the no
pressure Network you've been uh you've
been on two episodes yes of hey baby we
kept it rolling favorite oh that's right
have you gotten a lot of love from that
so thank you and thank you out there
that's what we want to see yes
absolutely we love when people come on
and our audience gets you know to know
them and then you take some of the
audience with you that's the whole point
yeah it's great I love it and and you
were great and uh so some of you guys
already might know Ian some of you might
not uh Ian is hysterical and and he is a
very um you have a look you have you
have a way and a look about you you
carry yourself in a certain way not a
lot of people can pull off your look I
appreciate that I I I know to look well
I I also orbited this look at one time
in my life wait what do you mean you
orbited this look I orbited this look
and you experimented with your sexuality
[Music]
I like your whole Essence thank you
because you're well some people might
just say oh he's a scar guy you know
with a you know with the with the Bad
Brains and all that stuff but but but
it's not just it's not just that like
you you you have layers to your
interests and then how you present
yourself thank you and depending on the
day you might get a different slightly
different version of of of of of your
aesthetic and your style well today's
the version you guys are getting is is
um uh flight Finance right you just got
off a flight I just got off I literally
came from JFK to here and uh this is my
flight outfit I always wear I'll tell
you right now though I'm sitting on a
I'm sitting in my seat on a plane and
then I see you in this outfit I see you
enter the
I'm like I'm doing that thing under my
brother please [ __ ] don't please
please [ __ ] don't please don't sit
next to me because I'm a good plane Hank
I keep to myself I have a little blanket
I put on and I just I do my Nintendo
twitch music movie asleep I don't
bothering the whole routine and you
would have probably proved me wrong you
would have someone who sat next to me
and I'm like look at that it wasn't that
bad yeah but and I know you so that now
I know but if I just saw you sight
unseen I would say there's gonna be
multiple issues here a lot he's going to
smell like smoke probably uh well um
I get told I don't smell like smoke okay
and that means a lot to me okay yes okay
and I smoke in my studio and people go I
can't even tell you smoking lines
they're lying yeah you're lying no no
you might not smell like smoke if you
hadn't just had a cigarette but if you
smoke normally in do I smell like smoke
right now I don't smell you no good you
smell great that's great but you do have
the marble Reds right in the top Pock I
do so when was the last time you sucked
down one of those uh I'm sitting out on
the playground waiting for you guys to
finish the last episode interesting we
don't smell them no we don't I'm telling
you it is insane people don't smell me
they say you go I got air filters at the
Wazoo okay and my apartment does your
winter coat smell
yeah yeah but it's it reminds me you
know childhood it's nice it's like a
throwback Thursday whoever I'm around
also to go back to the plane I've
noticed a lot of people pop their shoes
off now
yeah
hello ring ring ring comfortability on
the phone yes that's nice is that a Tom
Sharp I don't know my best friend got
them
Acorn you wear those on the plane wear
them on the plane that's Soul Candy I
bring them dude this is a slipper bro
you just slept with this out in the wild
no no no I can't even change on the
plane I change on the plane no you Mr
Rogers it you you literally get on pop
off your shoes and pop on I popped the
slippers on and I go hello there
neighbor oh wow and then they go I would
be very confused because if I saw him
popping off the shoe when he was next to
me I'd be like here we go here we go but
then he takes out a softer shoe and then
he makes a comfortability play yeah and
then I'm like who is this that I dress
for Comfort yeah
layers to you yes now I I also I think
shorts on a plane is like a No-No for me
I sweat I'm a sweater okay so you are a
sweater I'm sweating right now I gotta
take this well then if you don't smell
like smoke do you smell like sweat
possible Bo me no I shower before
flights you do I do so it sounds like
you're peeing before you get in the pool
so you're very considerate yes I bring
come across as considerate
that's all I gotta [ __ ] extra hard to be
considerate because I know what I look
like you're bringing slippers bro I
bring slippers to friends houses I bring
them to hotels if I'm going to a pool
party I'll bring them I love it because
I don't want to wear shoes in someone's
house you know I I don't allow shoes in
my house I wore shoes here last time I
felt bad about it ever since
you brought a new tension I brought my
own slippers but let me ask your
question no
no no see I wouldn't let you wear those
in my house either what what you wear
those those are street legal for you
yeah I'm not wearing these on the street
but you wore them on a plane yeah a
plane's not a street I'm wearing them in
a little seat carpet but other people's
shoes from the street yeah back on the
plane oh never mind that all the pissing
[ __ ] from the bathrooms in the in the
air I'm not wearing these in the
bathroom no I'm putting the shoes back
on the point is that the carpet on the
plane is embedded with the urinal ready
right you don't come home you ever take
your shoes off on a plane yeah yeah sure
you could say it
you you come home you take those socks
off before you start walking around your
apartment right because those socks so
okay so so then socks off yeah if they
touch the carpet on the plane these are
my travel slippers by the way I have
these same exact slippers at home I put
those on I come in my house take my
shoes off put my slippers on walk around
right and then when I TR these are my
travel slippers
when we appear yes I have the same I
have backup shoes of things that I yes I
do that too but but you should know that
the carpet on the plane and I think I'm
not talking at a school here at a turn
is is filthy they don't they don't
vacuum that they vacuum they don't hit
that with a stainless Stanley Steamer no
way they don't hookah who vacuums it
we're what when when who when who win
when those they have guys that go on the
play that's why who did it when they do
it and what do they do with the playing
guys
they got playing guys
phones that vacuum they don't you don't
think they vacuum they do not you don't
think they wipe the seats down they
vacuum I think that they try to project
that they do that in coveted times well
they go around and they crisscross the
seat belt buckles they do yeah look on
Delta flight every seat buckle is
crossed like this I'm sure they do a
sweep maybe with gloves and pick up like
a popcorn kernel something they see
that's that's egregious but they're not
getting in there with like a Dyson and
giving a real house well they should
because guess what it'll create more
jobs
on the way in yes why don't they do that
I'm seeing a girl who is a former flight
attendant and she said you can get E
coli from the coffee on a plane next
water the coffee on the plane I don't
turn it through the Brita and they don't
change cleaning it ever yes that's the
same for hotels
so I have extra slippers at my apartment
that I give guests so do I with with my
face monogrammed on well not now okay
that's crazy that's amazing for my
podcast they're beanie and slippers
that's amazing and I ordered pizza
sandwiches so when you come over you get
a sandwich and a slipper I love that
Merchant sandwiches what are we doing I
know I would love a slipper yeah I'm
living in a high rise in Staten Island
what am I doing I got double pairs of
slippers for Planes Trains and
Automobiles that's what I'm doing you're
doing it right I'm going in the poor
house so I can get to step on top geez
when he comes over what am I doing in
his wide foot won't even fit the slipper
he got slippers you'll get slippers too
when you come over all right now I do
have uh last time Joe and Q actually
visited the ditch I I know that I heard
that so we have the should we should we
wait to roses for that ah look at that
picture of him screen it just so the
fans don't miss him too much all right
so they're all right so so just so you
know although your socks are going in
some bad news on the plane so when you
go home you don't want to you want to
take peel those socks off those socks
the bottom of socks essentially become
like the bottom of your shoes how often
do you change your socks
what do you mean
what do you mean like daily right
you wearing your socks from morning to
night
oh yeah so it's daily unless unless they
get hot unless I'm out and I come home
and they were hot I'll two to three
times a day I'm changing the socks you
do so you do sweat a lot I got three
pairs I sweat so do you sweat you have
socks in your bag when you go around
you're biking around
yes I gotta have extra stuff because of
the bike sure sure now I noticed the the
t-shirt that was that a tank top or was
that a t-shirt that you made it was a
t-shirt I cut into a tank top Bad Brains
one of my favorite bands all the time
you ever hear of them of course I know
Bad Brains hell yeah they're great I
have an album all right too nice that's
old school stuff yeah yeah that's for me
but when did I discover Bad Brains I'll
call it
well when did I discovered them it
wasn't until probably high school yeah
but uh actually it was through the
Beastie Boys I discovered yeah Beastie
Boys start out as a hardcore punk band
on the Lower East Side playing at the A7
where the Bad Brains were chromags and
they were part of that whole scene
absolutely crazy it is crazy yeah I know
wild they're fantastic I know I love
them too yeah
I told you I I I I
peripherally am was that layers layers
you mirrored a couple of onions people
just think yeah we are onions peeling
them back
so what are we doing today Ian is guest
uh hosting with me we're doing a
lightning round today of worsts and it's
going to be non-food related something
we haven't done in a long time this is
something I really liked DeRosa wasn't
hot on the on this one and I really
loved it so we're gonna do three
lightning battles of which is worse the
first one is going to be what's worse a
broken umbrella or broken sunglasses
buddy you're saying that a broken
umbrella is worse broken umbrella is
worse than a broken home I'm gonna say
broken sunglasses uh the next one we're
doing is going to be
what's the next one we're doing is is
your ice cream melts or your coffee gets
cold which is worse iced coffee no
matter what iced coffee middle of a
snowstorm it's a blizzard I'm putting on
10 coats that smell like cigarettes to
go get a nice car I understand but I
think you're I think you're interpreting
this wrong right you're not ordering an
iced coffee you have a hot coffee yeah
and then it gets room temperature so
your hot coffee gets cold on you just
like your ice cream melting on you not
like cold coffee oh I'll drink a cold
coffee right but I'll drink a hot coffee
melted cold right I will drink that's
not a bummer to you that's a win that's
a win because guess what iced coffee is
my favorite I probably made a mistake
and ordered it hot okay all right so
we'll get we'll dig into that so yeah
you and you say melted ice cream is
worse it's worse yes okay and then we're
going to the third battle melted ice
cream is kind of good okay all right go
I know
uh and then the last one is what is
worse a stuffy nose or a sore throat
you're taking no's I'm taking three yes
stuffy nose all Terrible Things yes uh
let's go to Joe real quick and see
what's up so Joe do you know this about
Joe Joe's uh from a suburb in Philly
yeah and the next to his home he grew up
uh you know an only child yeah me too
and you did we talked about we didn't
talk about this but he had a ditch near
his home what it was
yeah yeah the the relate to me train
stops here you get a ditch near his home
and he used to go just alone and play in
the ditch and then he used to just sit
and he used to ruminate and pontificate
in the ditch as a child
[Laughter]
I got lightheaded what yeah so he used
to
be said he would just sit alone in a
ditch yes I feel like I'm gonna cry I
know it's sad but it's sweet and we knew
it complete when we wore a younger man's
clothes but last time we also learned
from him and Q that his adopted father
used to spend time in the ditch alone as
well it was a family affair oh I didn't
know that oh it was a family ditch it
was a family ditch okay and his father
before
I think the day like I think he used to
sit at the edge of the ditch and just
talk to himself and think things and we
have some footage him anymore so he went
back to the ditch recently
and he went back and visited the ditch
is this like is this like Woody
Harrelson and Kingpin when he goes back
to his little place in Ohio and he's
just like his life is over and he's just
so sad I know Kingpin but I don't
remember the specifics oh yeah they go
to kind of a ditch that was he was that
was the comb over right yeah what's his
name uh Bill Murray and Ernest that was
the Farrelly brothers right yeah one of
my favorite movies of all time yeah you
got to watch it again dude it is so good
it's what Randy Quaid right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah Randy Quaid has been on
like the lamb I think oh dude he's a
Looney Tune you'd think he'd have spent
his life hanging out in ditches yeah I
don't know I don't know I don't I don't
want I wish him I don't know what's
exactly it's fantastic but I think that
uh well who knows maybe he's I I think
he got caught up in like he thought the
government was tracking him or whatnot
and you know
to his credit hey you were right about
that Rand dog yeah we don't know we
really don't know like if they are and
no one's listening to the guy geez
Louise I don't think he's in the states
anymore or something like that really
I'm not sure well look I miss him I
loved him in movies and we wish him the
best yep that being said wow why did
Randy quick come because Kingpin came up
because this is a ditch so I guess we're
gonna do this without Joe but maybe
let's just do a teaser so there's a
video of him visiting his little ditch
let's just do the first like here we go
let's just do the first show goes home
Joe goes to the ditch you know we love
talking about better help here at the
taste buds podcast uh you know we're all
running in this Rat Race and we're
overwhelmed and I am overwhelmed 24 Sev
we got the holidays coming time to relax
and the Sun is gone he schedules are
toughening up if you like me my job is
I'm a professional Problem Solver that's
what I do all day long you just answer
and fix problems that's the job I have
uh but you know there's no better
feeling when you do have your own
Solutions and it can be tough to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode when faced with a challenge in life
a therapist can help you become better
at problem solving and make it easier to
accomplish your goals no matter how big
or small we've all tried better help
here on this pod we love it it's online
therapy you can get connected to a
therapist within 48 hours they are you
know therapists from all over so you
might get access to people that have
experience in places that aren't
available to you locally you don't even
have to put yourself on a screen it
could be all done online and you don't
they don't have to see you so lot of
times that's a that's something that is
a barrier to entry with people they
don't want to go to an office they don't
want to show themselves this is uh
revolutionizing that okay if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try better
help is a great option
uh if it's convenient it's accessible
it's affordable and it's entirely online
get matched with a therapist after
filling out a brief survey and switch
therapists anytime okay when you want to
be a better Problem Solver therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
taste buds today to get 10 off your
first month that's better help help.com
taste buds
guys what have you what are things
you've done or seen friends or loved
ones do to lose weight they're all
ridiculous things I know someone who did
a 30-day liquid cleanse I know people
who only eat between the hours of four
and six insane workout questionable teas
you gotta get a more sustainable
approach if you're looking you have to
change your lifestyle and that's where
Noom comes in new weight is ready to
help they're a psychology-based approach
empowers you with knowledge and support
to build lasting results it's not a fed
diet it's a different way of changing
their relationship you have with food
they encourage mindful eating and they
build a connection between your mind and
your body you have to re
re-re-reboot to what's going on up here
and and and start your relationship from
food from a a different perspective and
there's not many people doing this Numa
is the only one who advertises with us
that takes this approach
um and they have quick lessons there's
coaching involved it's very flexible
um and yeah every journey is different
so if you have tried all these other
things and you haven't tried Noom
um you know you might want to try it and
you could also like
basically uh tailor it to what your lost
weight goals are so that's easier too
it's not just do this and then whatever
you kind of
want to understand what you want noon to
do for you and you kind of go from there
more than 3.6 million people have used
uh Zoom to success and they focus on
progress not Perfection which is what I
was getting at so you don't beat
yourself up if one day you mess up it's
not all off the rails okay with noon
weight you get right back on track
because they think progress is not a
straight line uh there are off days
hallelujah 95 of customers say new
weight is a good long-term solution and
active numerous losing average of 15
pounds in 16 weeks give it a try if
you're sitting out there and you're like
I tried everything you haven't tried
NuMe try it if you're done trying
everything lose weight and try new
weight sign up for your trial today at
noon .com tastebud not buds okay that's
n o o m noom.com slash tastebud sign up
for your trial today
hey guys come see me on the road all
tickets are available right now at
savocanocounty.com uh my fall dates are
up to the end of the year I'm gonna be
next week I'm gonna be in uh Hamilton
Ontario and Toronto Toronto we've added
a show that's October 14th and 15th and
the rest of October we're doing the
Richmond Virginia the carpenter theater
Hershey Pennsylvania they added a second
show there that's selling fast
um
and
that is all for October November we're
in Knoxville Atlanta and Birmingham
we're also in Louisville and Evansville
and then it rounds out in December I'm
going to Florida to Orlando Jacksonville
and Tampa and Tampa we added a second
show and I end the year over in
California I'm doing Santa Rosa
California San Jose California and we
are doing Sacramento everything's on
sale right now merch is up I got solo
merch and all the podcast merch is up as
well at salvolcanocounty.com hope to see
you guys on the road October 2nd I'm
headlining stand up live Phoenix Arizona
October 5th San Jose Improv October 6
Bray improv October 7 Hollywood improv
and I'm going to be a Pittsburgh improv
punchline Philadelphia all November
December coming up emfinance.com
ianimal69 Twitter twitch and Instagram
and check out the podcast B and Ian
patreon.com
here we are all right all right action
here we are
this is uh
as some of the taste buds fans know I
used to sit as a child and stare into it
what this is the ditch
this is the ditch this looks like when a
convicted murderer takes the police to
show them where they hit the body
yeah yeah
less ditchy I pictured it as a real it
goes down clearly right
you can yeah you probably can't see it
on camera but faintly through those
trees over there
you can see that there's a house yeah
and then there's a house there which my
neighbor our neighbors they still live
there Mrs Lutz still lives in that house
I know that perfect
and this fence this is the house I grew
up in it now looks quite different wow
nice front oh my God
this is Christ
Joey doesn't live there right now though
property line fence here I guess wow
this is what this is
but our fence was a chain link fence and
it ended
when I lived here somewhere around where
that tree is over there that has the
swing on it
that's a massive piece of prop so this
was set back we had a little you had a
little footing a little distance between
you and the ditch I'd sit against the
fence there
physical or emotional
nothing going on dude none of these
trees were in here
I mean some of them must have been look
at his disbelief at the passage of time
I mean I don't think all of these trees
grew in that time
[Music]
I'm telling you a lot of this was not
here
um you would think plus you would think
like literally though not even that like
he's he's like you know uh Kevin Hart
going back to Philadelphia being like so
that would come yet in Chicago be like
this is the house I grew up in like you
would think something Monumental
happened here the way that he's telling
the story we need an album live from the
ditch live oh my God he should he should
do his special from the ditch oh my God
just clearing around the ditching around
do you understand if that's what we
could get seats around that people come
to the ditch oh my God Joe that's a
great idea that is original as [ __ ] yeah
it's so funny imagine like Excavating a
little bit cleaning it up a little
putting seeds around and he does it from
the middle of the ditch no and we film
him clean it himself yes yes like Hey
Arnold oh my God Joe but you get him in
the room do that so he's just cleaning
up adopt a highways like doing community
service
dude DeRosa live from the ditch live
from the ditch is amazing it is amazing
and he just gives his little talk up
front about how he used to sit here
alone in a ditch and he was lonely and
now he wants to do how long now look how
far how long is this he does another
five minutes
seven minutes
used to be here and uh what do you know
trees grew and uh Mrs [ __ ] that old
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
stop stop
pulling the weeds out of the ditch
he's re-ditching We buried all our pets
there Joseph
and I'd love to give an update The
punishment's Happening soon we're still
trying to find the right costume okay
we've been so what has happened so okay
so are we we we uh a season of taste
buds is 52 weeks for two episodes at the
end we compare our records yeah and
whoever loses gets punished and now
we've yet to we've yet to carry through
with it wow what's the punishment
Joe yeah
that was tossed around
as a matter of fact our our second I
mean the the second year tally that's
why I asked you to get the stats is
coming up because it's 104th episode is
the second season and we're in the high
90s right now oh wow and I don't I don't
know I gotta be honest I know this time
I don't know who's who's winning or not
myself
I'll pull it up I'm not sure yeah if we
can get that up because I wanna I want
especially in the run up to 104 like if
there's a chance that we're close enough
that it could be anybody's game I want I
want to have those stakes in the next 10
episodes I think the rose will lose it
if we double punish him
I know so let's let's find out though
because if we're at like episode like 98
or whatever it is is he afraid of
heights I don't know I am but I don't
know but I I you know you know what I'm
saying though right if there's a chance
it's close enough where he could still
well I could still come back and win
let's take that over the next few
episodes with us like that tense
what if he goes double or nothing
oh no I won't do it because his first
his first I won't do it because his
first punishment is he has got to he's
obsessed with McDonald's I don't know if
you know this yeah in 100 episodes he's
brought up McDonald's in everyone really
he's obsessed and it was he said they're
they're the only people that were there
for him
shut up you say they have concierge
service he said they have concierge
White Glove service they're there for
you through the ups and downs and when
he was little like
is this guy living his Creature Comforts
her [ __ ] burgers and ditches I know
poor job
my pendulum has swung his way a little
bit because the empathy is coming in
hard yeah and someone's backing up an
empathy truck and dumping it all right
here so he's got a bartend at his bar
fully dressed I mean fully as Ronald
McDonald I mean also said he has to bark
coupons for the yeah and he has to bark
outside first oh dude amazing I mean but
we the reason it's taking long is we're
not going to get like a a like an out of
the bag Ronald McDonald we want him to
you want to be like bro I had a cousin
who was a Ronald McDonald no he went to
clown college I'm seeing him this
weekend in Phoenix
wait a minute wait a minute okay time
out a couple things are you wait wait
wait I swear to God I feel like if you
go to clown college but then you become
Ronald McDonald you are a failure
because Ronald McDonald isn't doing name
a better clown that's that name name a
bigger clown I agree with you but what
I'm saying is anything that he's
studying in clown School Ronald McDonald
is not he's not doing any of those
things he's a spokesperson he's a
figurehead yeah but he's not going
around juggling spraying [ __ ] out of out
of his lapel bro are you kidding me that
just makes Ronald McDonald even better
imagine being a kid and seeing imagine
being a kid seeing Ronald McDonald and
you're like whoa what it can't get any
better
but he doesn't do that though this guy
did oh you're saying that he
he leveled up round because he had the
skill set to do clown things yes yeah
but if you you know because you know
what I'm saying though right like Ronald
is almost like I wonder if the clown
Community shuns Ronald
but what are the clowns in in appearance
only
nothing he does very few people he comes
there and endorses there's old pictures
of him juggling there's got to be
there's got to be he's got to be a a
trick type clown because otherwise it's
a man dressed as a clown giving food to
children that's what it is that's what
I'm saying I don't want to live in that
world that's what I don't want to live
in that world guess what how old are you
look at him you've been living in it
look at him there he is juggling what's
he doing here Ronald McDonald oh that is
[ __ ] oh my God I mean he is like what is
a large Ronald that is a large one says
Ronald gets serious about preventing we
know Ronald McDonald House you know what
that is right that's an amazing thing
that is so that's like where I always
used to drop my coins in the plastic
house oh yeah that's nice I mean a
change I always put in there even as a
child yeah yeah what about you I do get
what you're saying but there's very few
clowns who can break through to make a
new headlining clown he is a crossover
clown for African-Americans to the
whites yeah yeah but I'm just gonna say
though
I don't think he really does tricks is
that a Polynesian Ronald that's amazing
wow he looks Polynesian yeah dude I'm
telling you I really think Ronald is a
trick guy I don't think he is some of
these Ronalds look I mean hella
terrifying yeah terrifying look ah no
that's not good somehow the rose is not
here and yet his spirit
McDonald's has a conversation piece I
think he will haunt you till you die
yeah it will look at that Ronald some of
you guys look you can't here's the thing
about Ronald that we're learning okay
you can't just put on the costume and
the makeup and look like Ronald that's
not enough if you look weird and you put
on the weird makeup you're gonna look
like a weird Ronald yeah you know but we
we put someone put up a they did a draft
of Joe as McDonald Ronald and he looks I
swear to God I see it I swear to God
makeup remover and just remove Ronald's
face I swear to God he has to look like
to Rosa because they look alike oh my
God
dude I'm telling you
I distinctly remember seeing my cousin
Brian as raw McDonald juggling do you
think that he might have the outfit
still or no
this was a long time ago I don't know
but if he does let can you yes can yes
we'll give him credit we'll keep it in
great condition we'll overnight it back
to him I'm gonna see him this weekend
I'll find out that'd be amazing I think
it would be great to have him come and
train Joe on how to really properly do
it I mean I would love that that would
be incredible tab Joe take Ronald
classes how do you Ronald can you Google
that how do you become a Ronald McDonald
because they're out there right yeah
well I don't know if they still do this
but when you had your party there you
could pay an extra Scott all you could
you could break them off more and then
Ronald made an appearance you know that
really was your cousin I haven't seen a
Ronald in a location I haven't seen a
first-time party at a McDonald's in
forever either yeah yeah I want to go
back to a time where that was a treat
we're going to a McDonald's throw one of
our birthday parties out of McDonald's
December 31st hello it's on New Year's
Eve hello yes that's gonna be a tough
one to get people there on a New Year's
Eve though before the week before a week
after
I was thinking about doing laser tag but
that's just that's amazing yeah yes we
are we are the same there yeah do that
yeah
McDonald's keeps a roster of about 250
Ronald's worldwide according to
marketing experts familiar with the
program and franchisees with some
support from the company uh they pay for
Ronald as an advertising expense each
Major Market in the US has at least one
Ronald with large cities employing
several so how do you get to become a
Ronald let's see
should I call him can you call it let's
call him let's get him on the phone I
want to know the I want to know what's
up here
does Ronald McDonald make a lot of money
that can't be his only job but then
again if he's the only McDonald for that
National for that major city he needs to
be ready to be called upon at a moment's
notice he needs the Clown
I mean that and maybe he does like Santa
Claus on the side
that's his world do you think that
Ronald the Ronald do you think there's
no reason they shouldn't be proud and
own it right like if you were a Ronald
and you went on a date would you be like
I'm Ronald
no it's like Superman I can't tell
people Clark Kent's not being like I'm
Superman I mean if that's your main like
you're on date you're not gonna be like
I I'm Cleveland's Ronald
I think he weighed six months the
bizarre rules behind playing the role oh
my God this is fascinating to me and I
cannot believe I've never looked any of
this up here we go let's go on a ride
all right in the meantime I'm texting
cousin Brian okay text cousin Brian
let's get him on the phone I'm gonna
read these rules babe
one of the most important rules this
facts and rules okay let me read this
let me read this and I'll read the facts
and rules then I'm gonna get on to the
battle
remember Ronald McDonald the iconic cell
mod creep to remember him how stupid
everything is that somewhat creepy
mascot that you always saw at McDonald's
commercials they're writing to me like
I'm I'm an alien uh the role isn't as
simple as slapping on some makeup and
learning how to juggle there are pretty
bizarre rules that the characters are
quite required to follow check out these
mind-blowing facts about McDonald's
let's go there first pimp that first
link
uh there's some good stuff right here
okay one of the most important rules of
playing the McDonald's mascot is that
Ronald you listen to this babe Ronald is
never allowed to reveal his true
personality
wait meaning the human beings
right you're not allowed to break you're
not allowed to break character when he's
in the costume The Only Name he goes by
is Ronald McDonald the company also
likes to pretend that there is only one
Ronald but they tend to keep up he's
like uh Saddam he's like
when he leaves the McDonald's it's like
six clown cars and you don't know which
one he's in okay
they do tend to keep a lot of Secrets
how does Ronald appear in multiple
countries at the same time on the same
day how the secret menu items created
didn't know there was secret menu items
these are ways things we may never know
but because of the image that McDonald's
likes to hold no two Ronalds are ever
allowed to be spotted together
oh wow cousin Brian can't tell me
anything because they have to sign
numerous waivers saying they'll never
reveal what they learned working for the
company I he needs to break it's a
hypocratic oh it's a wrong he's like I
can't dude hit below but you're you're
family though yeah true also you know
we'll do a mod we'll modify his voice oh
yeah if we get him on the phone and he
talks give him the give him that like uh
that 20 20 treatment when they're behind
us yeah yeah like well I was wrong
uh it gets weirder McDonald's okay
Ronald's rules and regulations don't end
there McDonald's had to supply our own
shoes
[Laughter]
I juggled the balls weren't the only
thing I juggled juggled many women you
don't want to know what goes on in the
ball pool
the ball pit has a different meaning for
me the Hamburglar was a legitimate felon
in 1972 McDonald's boss clown named AJ
who was in charge of overseeing and
hiring and training of the Ronalds
created a guide called Ronald
and how to easily train a new employee
these are the bizarros here we go
to never allowed to hug kids good rule
okay yeah they're only supposed to Pat
the children on the back wow send us a
photo
uh hashtag Ronald hugs if you've ever
had a party you'll have a picture of
Ronald hugging someone breaking protocol
wow hashtag Ronald hugs
um you know I had a birthday clown that
I was obsessed with when I was younger
his name was Bingo okay there's a that
was his name-o a local Newport Delaware
clown how do you become a fan of a local
clown well he was at the ground round
one time how do you know yeah really
yeah free popcorn and black and white
cartoon and they'd give you food based
on how much you weighed and like a penny
system oh that's right remember yeah
yeah that's right I forgot about that
deal if you the kid got on a SK no no
you told them how much you weighed and
then they charge you a penny for every
pound there's a penny for a pound for
your Meats that's correct what yeah I
gotta find this photo because it is
haunting the way this clown looks and
the look on my face things happened I
think really maybe that's why I do
comedy now right maybe that's why you're
right maybe that's why you're cutting
your regular t-shirts Into Thin tanks
you've never done that for Summertime
Summertime Sal is not wearing tanks I
don't do a low arm tank you have a low
swooping arm it's like a deep V yeah I
understand that but that's what I was
gonna say before when I see you get on
the plane with your own made homemade
tank top I'm like you have to smell
because you're allowing this area kimchi
would you like to yeah that's once One
Step removed from topless to me that's
fair yeah that's fair I'm seeing your
nipple I'm seeing your your hair oh
you're welcome yeah I thought I'd bring
again get through the rules here okay
um they had to sign numerous waivers
saying that they'll never reveal what
they learned working for the company
let's see if we can break that today or
also you know what if we don't get Brian
on the line if we have a fan who was a
McDonald's clown please write in the
comments on this video right now let us
know you were a clown we will interview
you next time oh my god dude whoa it's
me and bingo that's Bingo that's bingo
bingo has a picture of himself on his
own shirt that he's wearing yeah Bingo
got in some trouble later Ghostbusters
too yeah sure yes later in life I think
he got in trouble wow
and he had a Newport Delaware accent and
we have videos of him at my birthday
parties being like did you snowy Ian was
a strong boy
how strong you are hit the hammer Ian
can you text him so we could throw this
out yeah you look like a deer in the
headlights you know it's like blink
twice
yeah haunted truly haunted what does
Bingo do but he was my favorite I don't
know your parents hired him yeah I mean
this isn't my house they brought a clown
into our house you caught him at the
Ground Round then you'd rather love or
massive neglect yeah yeah yeah you
caught him at the ground run was there a
was there a background check on Bingo
buddy this was like 91. yeah yeah they
didn't care about that so something's
got to change yeah yeah
all right
uh they had to promote the idea of fun
to their customers they shouldn't
directly promote the food
you know what these aren't bad rules
um if kids ask you can't tell them that
Burgers come from cows what wow and what
are you supposed to do then live yeah
yeah what do you tell them you lie to
the child come from the kitchen
so that that tells me that McDonald's
is I is is identifying guilt that
they're guilty they don't want to tell
the kids you should be guilty
they should feel guilty for what for
serving great food to DeRosa exactly for
their concierge he said they have
concierge service wait what is concierge
service like McDonald's like I know
that's what we said like like white
glove like like five-star Michelin
service what is he talking about they
never fail you the service is always
like as good as you can get out of
McDonald's has he not watched a video on
Twitter lately I know
jumping behind registers because they
didn't get the sauce they wanted I know
not exactly White Glove service buddy
McDonald is half the McDonald's in New
York in New York City are like the
beaches of Normandy
you ever go into the one next to the fat
flat next to the view oh they it shut
down shut down you go to the one at 34th
and eighth that's the spot yeah that's
where all the homes that one's by Joey
Rose's downtown the guy came in with the
axis the one on Broadway is 24 hours a
second
yeah they're playing piano in that one
24 hours two floors there's a piano on
the second floor really I swear
on the McDonald's yeah on Third Street
though it's a fifth a 50 50 shot that
you're getting you're getting hit in the
face if you walk in there bro 50 50.
yeah it's not dude the one into Lancey
that's the guy that had the the ax going
around
oh that was that was yeah that was a
McDonald's The Landing Essex was it when
he broke the window yeah oh but I think
I think did they catch that guy yeah
they caught him and they were they
slapped them on the wrist they're like
no do it again buddy no yeah they caught
him and let him out that night yeah well
because we didn't see what happened
before he went on the news and defended
it and said he had to scare them but
then he threatened a woman no it seems a
little and then Kevin Brennan had him on
the Pod no he didn't yeah and they gave
him a sword yeah
did the guy was he all there did he see
him all there he seemed like a fun guy
yeah he seems all right
what did he say you're like Ronald now
you can't talk bad about the guy just
promote fun
what what did um what what did what was
his reasoning is that charade no doing
an ad for [ __ ] shut up
oh my God that is small doing an ad oh
no I might show up on one of these I did
a bunch of these I swear to God I might
show up
dude I'm in some of these
oh my God
[Laughter]
that's integrated into society Ian he's
so good there you go back what am I
saying
Katie
wait what is this though
I mean yeah she probably wanted a lot of
things having to be with Prince Charles
Prince Charles is like the English Lyle
Lovett it's like how are you
yeah yeah
whoa what's up suck it Queen what was
that it was for readers
what were you talking about years ago I
did this thing for Reader's Digest it
was like a talking head thing and they
put it on ads on like you're on Reader's
Digest website right now oh what are the
chances dude
we went to Reader's Digest website and
years ago you did a talking exercise and
it popped up on the screen that is
that's weird that's amazing what does
that mean My grandmother used to say
it's something like that happened she
used to be like play the lotto oh which
I never made the connection I'm like why
you're going in a home
put on pan
my grandma God bless us she would play
the pick three and the Pick Four like
and every day she would justify how
close she was because she would make the
numbers that came out she would attach
them to anything so she'd be like oh 302
came out that's my area code by the way
that's something weird
dude something weird's going on I swear
to God all three battles yeah this is
weird yeah she used to go 302. she's
like three is the third month March your
aunt was born in March and O2 In 1902
the blah blah blah and I'd be like but
that you can do that with anything
anyway
Rita's digest and you did that years ago
and now they're using you now was that
in perpetuity you signed that no it was
it
years later you're on their website I
know it's crazy it was weird to see
charade on there yeah and we're like oh
look at this idiot
I made him rewind to hear my joke
could you imagine I didn't notice Girard
and then we looked up and you were just
I'm just on your TV yeah wow that's wild
wow that's amazing let's check out his
next rule of Ronald and it does it it
doesn't match the clown we just saw they
have to be fit or at least have a body
that appears to be it or what does that
mean and you have to have a body that
appears to be fit is there a physical
fitness so what they're like we're not
we're not taking off the jumper but it
should not look like you fill the jumper
up I mean that guy's face what's that
was so fat that one right I mean that
was a yeah that was I mean those pounds
of red makeup for that guy they had to
be uh they had to follow a script when
answering questions like oh I like like
Siri
um if they don't answer if they don't
have an answer that fits their
instructor say ask someone wearing
normal shoes I want to stump a Ronald I
know I want to make a Ronald squirm
[Music]
this is what we need to do okay this is
what we need to do we need to get a
Ronald on we need to get a Ronald on in
full outfit and put him behind the black
silhouette change his voice and then go
down this whole list and he needs to be
like a deep throat like he needs to be
like a a Wikileaks round yes we got to
do a whole Ronald expose what if we set
it up where De Rosa thought it was a
dating show
and behind the Chris
oh my God
that's great round number two next same
question it's like this and it's a
silhouette of a woman but she comes out
in her bra stuff with cheeseburgers
taste buddies let's talk about bombas
mamas is uh a new uh they're advertising
with us for the first time I believe and
I actually am already a customer of
bombas uh they are they make socks I
they might make more we'll find out I'll
see here but they make the best damn
socks and I've been wearing them for a
long time uh Mama's mission is simple
make the most comfortable clothes ever
and match every item sold with an equal
item donated that's exactly what they do
so when you buy bombas you are also
giving to someone in need I'm not
kidding I bought four dozen bomba socks
uh this last holiday as gifts of packs
of of uh 12 for people because they're
kind of really cool the designs are
awesome they're really comfortable bomba
socks design their sock shirts and
underwear to be the clothes that you
can't put I can't wait to put on every
day everything they make is soft it's
seamless and tagless which I love and
has a cozy feel there's a pair of socks
for everything you do they come in tons
of options like comfy performance Styles
made with sweat wicking Yarns which
means your feet stay cool while the rest
of you works up the sweat that's true I
have those they work great
bombas no show socks which I also have
are designed for Comfort while being
specifically engineered to never fall
down to let your ankles be free to soak
up the sunlight that's another thing
that I can't stand bombas is one of the
only people that do the no-show sock
that doesn't fall off my heel mamba's
t-shirts are made with thoughtful design
features like invisible seams soft
fabrics and the perfect weight so they
hang just right so there you go they
also make t-shirts and underwear which I
didn't know when I'm going to look up
bomba's underwear is so breathable it
fits so well it feels like you're
wearing nothing at all in a good way and
did you know that socks underwear and
t-shirts are the three most requested
clothing items at homeless shelters
that's why bombas donates one for every
item you buy so far Obama's customers
like you have helped donate over 50
million items of essential clothing
that's crazy go to bombas.com taste buds
and use code taste buds for 20 off your
first purchase that's bombas
b-o-m-b-a-s.com taste buds and use code
taste buds to check out bombas.com taste
buds code taste buds hellofresh
with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes they've delivered right to your
doorstep that's a sentence that has so
many appealing words in it Farm Fresh
ingredients seasonal recipes right to
your doorstep skip trips to the grocery
store uh count on hellofresh make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's America's number one meal kid
and we all know that
subscribe to hellofresh and check save
money off your full to-do list because
it's cheaper than takeout and even the
grocery store sometimes 25 percent
cheaper okay uh ingredients travel from
the farm
right to your doorstep ding dong in less
than seven days so you know they're
fresh plus the pre-portioned ingredients
make cooking a snap and cut down on food
waste because I do that I'll go to the
I'll go to the grocery store and I'll
buy something and then it goes
especially with fruits fruits and things
like cold cuts and things like that I'll
buy them and then they'll go bad I live
alone and I cannot finish this one I
don't I don't understand portion control
when I'm actually food shopping this
cuts that out
um they're all for vegan recipes now
on uh on the menu every week uh made
without animal products of any kind like
Dairy meat eggs or honey and joy meals
like sweet chili tofu bowls or spicy
coconut curry stir fry
um plans are flexible you can choose
meals for the week update your
preferences change your delivery day all
in a hellofresh app uh like I said I use
it it's as convenient as possible I I
change it on the fly it really is simple
to use okay go to hellofresh.com
tastebud65 and use code tastebud65 the
numbers for 65 off plus free shipping
um there's not a lot of people that give
that good of a deal go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds six five and use the code
tastebud65 for 65 off plus free shipping
uh hellofresh America's number one meal
kit guys you asked for it for so long we
finally got it merch is on sale right
now uh we really talk about it but I
want to start pushing it because we have
a really cool designs that Joe and I
made up ourselves and it's the limited
run so whatever is on sale now the
second is sold out it's not coming back
it's available right now uh in the links
on these videos or at our website
savocanocomedy.com Joe derosainfo.com
that's tastebuds merch I also have solo
merch uh up there as well uh and uh so
check all of it out and uh and and buy
some merch tweeted us the merch and we
will retweet you we'll repost you on
Instagram we want to see which ones you
guys are liking and we want to see the
merch out in the wild
I want to have Ronald on we'll protect
his ident
and and when we ask him the hard-hitting
questions though and we modulate his
voice and then we find out all the
secrets let's see if he can ruin
McDonald's for DeRosa if you are a
Ronald let's see if we can rule
everywhere around the world Noah Ronald
and you live in the tri-state area of
the United States of New York
Pennsylvania Jersey please please write
in the comments or or what's your what's
our email address uh well tastebudspod
Gmail.com Gmail you scan that you'll
find that put Ronald McDonald in all
caps or hashtag it or throw it down and
hashtag it on IG what should I say to
cousin
he's you got him on the line he texted
you back I I should I say hey would you
be willing to talk in a podcast real
quick yeah yeah promote the idea of fun
isn't that just being fun
yeah but it was a link so I just thought
they had a list of stuff it's like not
like Ronald's gonna show up and be like
today we're talking about G for genocide
but in a fun way yeah all right
um worse okay broken umbrella broken
glasses okay both uh I'm I'm assuming
that this to mean like at an inopportune
time like you go to get your umbrella ah
um you gotta get your sunglasses ah you
know not just like you're having a
broken umbrella in the house so you have
a pair of broken signals put into
practice right when you need it so I
understand that while you're taking
umbrella because umbrella you need it in
an emergency situation and if you don't
have it you're getting rained on there's
nothing I hate more than being wet I
would infinitely rather live in the
Revenant than have to be wet in a that
much Mist yes I love snow is fine dude
and your glasses guy the rain on your
glasses they're fogging up you're gonna
when you walk in a building you can't
see somebody told me to make that not
happy you should walk into the building
backwards like some sign is kind of
[ __ ] weird cat or something I'm like
no what are you insane here's the thing
with the broken umbrella right okay half
the time I have an umbrella I don't even
know when I should open it like what
because here's the thing if you open an
umbrella when it's very lightly
drizzling very lightly you look like an
idiot I don't care what I look like
because
but but you also look like an idiot when
it's drizzling and you're holding an
umbrella that's not open yeah but a lot
of times if it's not monsooning I'll be
like I can make it you know from the car
into the supermarket or I'll make it
from you know this building into the cab
you know we'll see here you're a cab car
guy I'm a bicycle walk guy okay train
guy okay so I can't I mean when I was
living back in Delaware yeah no big deal
umbrellas are part of a New York's New
Yorkers Arsenal that's true you
umbrellas are part of a new yorker's
Arsenal you gotta have an umbrella you
gotta have a weapon uh you gotta have a
charger you I mean when you leave you
gotta prepare for the elements of the
day and the umbrella is your most
important weapon how many times are you
getting caught in rain that warrants an
umbrella though I cannot tell you the
hatred and anger I have towards myself
when I get caught out in the rain and I
didn't look ahead with the weather and
you either get soaked or you have to buy
another umbrella I will cancel that five
dollar umbrella and that's it breaks and
I can't use it as a cane I love using
umbrellas as canes that's half the fun I
just cleaning it around that is super
fun that's my favorite there's nothing I
could say about not yeah yeah open it
you twirl it like the penguin but but
umbrellas are built to break I think I
really do think that well and enough is
enough you know our dear friend James
McCarthy said umbrellas belong to the
universe okay because sometimes you lose
them someone takes them you find it and
umbrella comes back umbrellas if I'm
weighing the amount of times I actually
need an umbrella in like let's say in a
in a in a one year span that I actually
need one and the amount of times also in
a one-year span that an umbrella breaks
it pisses me off so much that it's
almost like I'm used to it oh is it a
broken oh no [ __ ] it's my eighth one
this year also I'm not getting caught
where it's it's that bad for me it sucks
if it happens once it sucks but it's not
happening enough broken sunglasses I
think
sunglasses are harder to come by they're
more expensive if you're not just
getting like a five ten dollar I mean I
guess you could I guess an umbrella and
a pair of glasses can be expensive and
you could buy the ones from the corner
fine but like
sunglasses more than you're using
umbrellas correct I am the opposite
I think I think most people are wearing
umbrellas more than they're using them
wearing sunglasses wearing sunglasses
more than they're using umbrellas I
think they're supplies for most people
and I think I think I'm so used to an
umbrella being broken if I see it I'm
like Another One Bites the Dust yeah but
I'm not used to my glasses being crushed
sometimes I have sunglasses I have maybe
five six sunglasses some of them I've
had for 10 years if one of those breaks
I'm gonna feel it I'm gonna feel
disappointed okay if I'm out and it's
just it's blazing hip-hop and R B out
there and it's and it's and it's hot and
and I look at my sunglasses are broken I
am gonna just be like oh you gotta be
I'm not gonna be able to navigate really
yeah I guess I've just been so no
sunglasses for so much of my life that I
don't even think about I know I don't I
used to not wear sunglasses because I
didn't think I could pull them off I got
glasses so I can't but you could wear
the uh transitionals right
but what I mean hold on hold on top
every Mall Cop I knew growing up
I have um I have sunglasses that are a
prescription I put I put yeah but then
you got to take these off and put the
others and then you're just hanging here
oh that's difficult but you can carry an
umbrella as a chain all right what's the
next battle
uh I I will tell you in an instant I'll
put big aviators over my face if you
boil it down to one instant I think that
if it was like all right one time and
one time only broken umbrella glasses I
would go maybe umbrella but like if
you're just talking about in general I'd
be more bummed out if I kept breaking
sunglasses then I kept breaking
umbrellas because I already you're gonna
break the umbrella You're Gonna Break It
We all do it yeah yeah we've all broken
10 umbrellas a year we've all done it
yes yeah I don't break all my glasses so
for me that's gonna be more of a shot in
the chops right and and while it might
be more of a bummer to get wet I just
think I use the sunglasses more often
and I they break way less often and so
it's more of an event for me to
sunglasses break well one for shape I
could go underneath an awning if it's
raining yeah but also like if I'm out
and about this is going to be all day
I'm gonna be like this all day also
we're Foley weighing in see Foley I
[ __ ] love you umbrella for sure our
friend of comic uh broken Shades just
say you party yep
as a smoker I need the umbrella because
I'm going out in the store make a good
point then you really it really goes
it's really person to person it is I
think it is and I and I think then that
should mean that the battle is very
close I agree so we'll let's go to the
phones for a few of these and we'll move
on broken them it's all right babe uh
okay
um
okay wait just scroll up above fully for
a second oh
okay so this is this person saying so
now I'm either soaked or I have to
squint I hate broken sunglasses but
umbrella is a more my man okay okay they
make durable coats with hoods that can
help protect you from the rain if an
umbrella breaks if your sunglasses break
there is no substitute well you're a hat
a hat a bill of a hat yeah but that's
great point a broken umbrella cause you
a broken umbrella because you really
ain't hot [ __ ] in your Oakleys okay
um I'm not that girl who's scared to get
her hair wet never was broken sunglasses
suck ass especially when you're hungover
and I am a lot well that does go back to
Foley saying you party yeah broken
sunglasses is the worst our reflex is to
power through and run through the rain I
live in Florida 99.9 of the time I
forget my umbrella and I even have it
but I never will forget my sunglasses
you're all going to be soaking wet in
the pouring rain uh shaking my head
couldn't be me though umbrella gang yes
uh I shop for sunglasses knowing that
they'll probably break but I shop for
umbrellas assuming they won't yes
yes bizarre I spend money
you're wrong you're spending money on
sunglasses you don't spend them on
umbrellas because you know especially in
New Yorker New Yorker you got the fight
the guys the guys come out of the crawl
spaces when it rains and they they just
they just emerge and they have just uh
umbrellas to sell you know what I mean
the world's most expensive umbrella is
fifty thousand dollars no
770 1300 no see these are that is the
dumbest thing I've ever seen I hope
whoever gets up die is that snake skin
that is disgusting
I hate you wow yeah I don't like you so
so let's just hit the phone one more
time so I think this is gonna be pretty
close pretty close
um broken umbrella are we doing them
that now or at the end we're doing it
now let's do it now all right we're at
the eight minute Mark uh we got you're
refreshed we got 6 000 votes so far an
umbrella on broken umbrella versus
broken sunglasses which is worse pimpy
let's get that Humble Pie uh the
percentage is on the board yeah oh no no
no
[Music]
umbrella you are skewing umbrella with
the comments it's it's a it's a it's a
good battle
56.9 more for me it just changed you got
a point one percent right now at the 6
000 votes 56.9 percent of people think
broken sunglasses is worse broken
umbrella coming in at 43.1 that is a
very solid that is a very solid battle
and I tell you that's one of the ones
that I think if we check it again at the
end of the episode with another four or
five thousand votes it might swing I'll
put I'll put a Ronald McDonald on it
okay
if he doesn't get back to us now yeah
let's still have him get back to us
he is he called
I feel like we got a column at this
point it's Destiny yeah I mean Ian
popped up on the end yeah it is all
right
cousin we will not use a last name he
said he'll talk about it in a third
party professional clown okay
yeah but you know I'm gonna end up
having an hour's worth of questions for
him
so why don't we why don't we kick it up
why he's calling right now yeah you got
it all right let's put this on pause
okay
hey hey you what's up what's up man how
are you doing that sound like the voice
of the world first question did he have
to change his voice or did he use that
voice can it can I put you on the phone
with my friend Sal yeah of course okay
hey hey how you doing good buddy so
Ian's here we're doing a podcast and
Ronald McDonald Ronald McDonald came up
and he said that at one point you you
worked as a Ronald McDonald
uh yes that's true okay do you have a
free hour
We're Gonna Change Your Voice
um what what year did you what year did
you were you were Ronald oh man it was
like 1994 to about 2001 so it was kind
of like you were a Ronald for seven
years he was a Ronald during 9 11. you
are Ronald during 9 11. I uh yeah it was
actually wait so wait was it your
full-time job it was my full-time job
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that this topic came up and Ian has a
cousin that we got on the phone that was
a full-time Ronald for seven years does
he have the costume yeah ma'am I've got
to do it for like 20 years okay so I
have so many questions
okay Brian here we go okay were you what
made you initially go we might not do
the rest of the battles we might have to
continue this or I might go late
whatever you need what made you
seek employment
as around were you dabbling with clown
[ __ ] already or was this just right
place right time was it something you
always thought about was it romantic for
you was this something that fell in your
lap and you were like I can't believe
I'm gonna do this I never thought I'd be
a Ronald
um we'll start that yeah I lost a bet
no way no way just kidding I'm just
kidding okay
that's amazing oh so yeah so I was doing
clown stuff like from the age of 12 it
was like a classic runaway enjoying the
circus type of story right for me you
you were yeah yeah so and uh you ran
away and joined the circus to be a clown
not far uh but you know like I was
juggling and doing magic when I was like
12 years old and was doing some like
kids theater and then I started doing
birthday parties and you know kind of
started kind of uh performing at bigger
venues yada yada go to college and then
like every weekend I'm doing like
festivals and I audition for Ringling
Brothers and Barnum and Bailey clown
college no way you have to audition for
the college you can't just cut a check
and they have faith in you no it's no
it's not like the variety
wait okay
yeah I'll give you money get my kid in
it
so okay so so so you must have clown
friends then yeah yeah you're one in
clown circles
we drive in a very small car together so
so is there like when you're when you're
when you're when you want to be in this
world and you have people like-minded
people that want to be in this world
like comedians outside of me and Ian
like you must be talking about the
nature of this world and and it's goings
on all the time right like oh I I I made
it onto Ringling Brothers I didn't I
booked this big gig I learned this new
trick yada yada as you said right
exactly is is Ronald McDonald like the
SNL is it is it like the why is it like
the Pinnacle like are you gonna be like
dude you know what I'm shooting for I
want to be a Ronald one day or is Ronald
looked at because I and tell me if I'm
wrong I was like I feel like Ronald is
kind of like an imposter syndrome type
clown because he doesn't Focus
on all the things that make a clown what
a clown is he just comes in in the
outfit and then he's you know just
talking with children and he almost like
clowns Stolen Valor it's Stolen Valor it
really is so so yeah so the the back up
to your first question right is like do
do we all talk like what clown gigs are
they're out there for clowns to go get
and yeah like everybody that's in
Ringling knew the boss clown of Ronald's
McDonald's this guy's AJ AJ
ah we just read about AJ you know AJ
yeah he just passed away like a week or
so ago
play the lotto we have to dedicate this
episode we had to what are the odds what
are the odds something's weird today
something's clear today we've had we're
having way too many coincidences happen
how do you know that AJ died a week ago
did you keep in touch is there a
newsletter is there an alumni letter
yeah there's a alumni face group of all
the former Ronalds oh my God I need that
this is as good as I had hoped holy [ __ ]
so wait so then so then did you have
other clown friends that weren't Ronalds
that became Ronald's with you and then
you had Ronald friends
yes
at all different walks of life could
become around so there's guys that were
magicians that became Ronald they're
guys like me that were like clowns that
became Ronald was there like Ronald
resentment actors we even had a couple
comedians that became Ronald so if
you're a performer who
comedians yeah there's a guy by his
stage name is Nick beef he was actually
in New York City for a while Nick
I's name
that wasn't his real name
that's hysterical he ended up being a he
ended up pushing pushing beef
pushing beef
oh my God seemed like a natural fit oh
my dude you're blowing up who is Nick
beef well I'll tell you what if if you
Google he actually owns the gravestone
next to Lee Harvey Oswald if you want to
check that out dude this ghost
Oswald we are gonna find out some [ __ ]
right now Nick beef is [ __ ] and
[ __ ] it is yeah if you pull on this
conspiracy string long enough you're
gonna find out that Grimace kill JFK
that's where we're headed so Nick beef
but what is Nick beef like why is he in
the why is there an article on the
Atlantic written about him
the name of the article is
cave mystery who is Nick beef yeah
oh my God
what was this who's his real name
Nick beef kind of sounds like a milk
which is kind of a McDonald's sandwich
on your podcast so okay what are you
doing today was it was there a fat
Ronald's who got cut yeah so okay so
okay you don't understand we haven't
done this at a minute one Brian can we
get you on a flight to New York City
okay all right all right all right all
right so Nick beef we remember let's get
let's try to get you and Nick beef on
the on the Pod so so all right so so so
so so was it like okay so Ian's question
was was there like Ronald resentment
yeah
[Music]
um
no so it was it was like a good gig to
get because it was a steady paycheck
right uh you could always count on count
on getting pretty good gigs you could
also do your side work at the same time
so I was still performing outside of
Ronald so it was a you know it paid the
bills pretty handsomely for the seven
years I did it so it was a pretty
desirable Gig if you were looking to get
out of Ringling wow okay so let's let's
go back so you already doing that so
what what what day do you wake up and
you say Ronald is the play now
oh yeah so I auditioned for Ringling
Brothers right and I got accepted the
clown college oh you did okay I was
gonna say all the Ronald McDonald's like
Ringling Rejects
yeah so I didn't actually end up going
to clown college so I I because I also
then auditioned for McDonald's because I
got I knew guys that were already
Ronald's and so I knew a couple guys
that did Ringling and then after
Ringling they went to McDonald's
and they said hey you can make a lot
more money by being Ronald than you
would yeah
no way and so I said well let me
audition so they had a couple of
openings
um and there's like they're on like
television markets right so I auditioned
and I got one of the I got offered two
spots
and I took one of them and so what's
your question Ryan yeah you you
auditioning to be Ronald on camera or be
Ronald at McDonald's
and be a clown for the children yes
exactly is right so what they did is
they booked me to go do my clown show at
a local McDonald's
or actually maybe a festival right it
was somewhere not even the zoo right so
I did a show on stage at the zoo
and um yeah they said hey that was great
so you got you know AJ saw the show and
then offered me a job so I turned down
the Rings
so all right so so I mean those must
have been some really big oversized
shoes to fill
Ed what um
you know somebody or yeah well everybody
knew who AJ was right so yeah he just he
was always on the lookout for talent and
so
it was to literally be on the lookout 24
sevs for Ronnie Ronnies yeah so what is
the audition like
this is a Harvey Weinstein you want to
be a clown kid that's pretty much it
usually he takes you out for sushi as
long as you like sushi you're good to go
yeah oh my God we're looking at AJ right
now he has a handlebar mustache oh yeah
king of the king of the cardies oh my
God
his phone number is up here
his literal phone number we can't call
him he died right yeah no yeah he'll
just go to that voicemail in heaven what
if you called that right now maybe about
a week ago what if we get his voicemail
maybe we leave a nice message yeah
you'll probably get it
he inspired a lot of people all right
maybe maybe we end the Pod leaving him a
nice message oh he's the master
schmoozer it says
so so he takes you for sushi this sounds
weird already man so he's not he's not
even is he asking you like tell me about
yourself tell me what experience you're
having is it just is it just a talking
or or is he like do me a favor right
this second like throw a [ __ ] pie in
your face right now
no not quite that it's more of a more of
a serious interview right they do a
background check uh which is a huge
thing right because McDonald's has a
reputation to protects so a more serious
no they they take whoever gets into the
suit very seriously and then
you get hired and he goes through some
training you learn how to put on the
makeup you learn the character so it's
it's you know you you get a brand uh
kind of indoctrination about who Ronald
is and things he can do can't do and is
AJ is AJ the one doing this with you
yeah yeah there's yeah there's a whole
basically I don't know what you want to
call it uh you know manual on being
Ronald about places you can go places
you can't go things you can do in
costume things you can't you know so
they protect the image uh extensively
throwing somebody into a you don't just
throw anybody into the Mickey Mouse suit
right they want to make sure they know
okay so so was that like an afternoon
was that like a month of training like
are you so so you're sitting at a table
if this is truly like a meeting as hero
this is yeah because this is when
something is fascinating no I love it
yell out any questions but I can't I'm
fast enough I love it so is it you and
AJ sitting there and he's and you're
staring at him and he's putting the
makeup on you yeah well no so you sat
with AJ and he put the makeup on and
then you followed him out and then you
put the makeup on next to him this is
and then
yeah and then and then he critiqued it
that's like the clown Mafia ceremony
yeah
a ceremony
what's the ceremony no I'm just kidding
what's the hardest part about it yeah
there was a week-long we went to
Milwaukee you saw him do his shows
you've got uh there's School shows we
did mostly School shows so you got the
oh so you Shadow you Shadow AJ yep you
basically kind of run as his assistant
during the shows and then at the end you
get to perform the show as Ronald with
AJ there and then after that year you're
in the wings well you're accepted I
should say right so you know there's I
heard there's stories where people went
to go work with AJ for the week and at
the end of the week AJ told him yeah
he's like no you're not Ronald material
what what what do you have to do to not
be Ronald material
say again what did he say what what do
you have to do to not like what's the
story like what's an AJ Ronald Horror
Story how do you get rejected
oh man how do you get rechecked you just
don't just know you're asking me elbow
you're not a good clown yeah yeah just
to not be funny what if you're an
amazing clown but you're not good with
makeup
uh you're probably not an amazing clown
whoa
wow
wow nailed it yeah what was the hardest
part about your job
uh
hardest part about the job it's probably
keeping the wig on straight to be honest
with you because that wig is made out of
synthetic and Yak hair and you always
have to style it so that was always you
the wig if the wig messy you kind of
look like a schmuck the wig was made out
of yeah red dyed Yak hair that's what
clown clown at PS it's they're
synthetics and I think maybe the Eye
Care at one point but that's what they
used to make uh clown wings out of I
think the wrong one was synthetic so if
and it was red right and you have the
wave makeup on and also weight makeup's
getting on the bottom of the red wig
crap so you constantly had to clean
those freaking things and so that was
that was probably the toughest part what
about like just piece of [ __ ] children
oh
they're fine yeah you you yeah you learn
to deal with kids of all ages anyone in
a vomit should have piss on you adult
adults were usually the ones that are
the biggest jerks right because they
start asking you the kind of like the
questions like you're not the real
Ronald and how'd you get this job in
front of the kids and the kids believe
right the kids want to believe they're
like all right I'm eating Ronald
McDonald we're signing an autographs
taking pictures and you know you're a
kid you kind of like uh they wouldn't do
that to Santa Claus yeah Spider-Man when
you're like six years old right some
adult comes up and says you're not a
real Spiderman you're a piece of your
[ __ ] parents yeah so that was that was
worth that upsets me kids are pretty
good do you have any uh McDonald's perks
uh well if you walk into a McDonald's
dress as Ronald McDonald they let you do
whatever you want
what
does that even mean I walk in I got to
work the drive through so I would like
I'd start at the one end and take the
order at the first window and then run
to the second window and have them their
food wait wait wait
wait wait would you would you buy would
you just pop in and they didn't know you
were coming yeah but then but wait wait
wait wait but but corporate setting you
there you oh you just went unpaid just
to stir [ __ ] up well not just on my it
wasn't like I was doing on my days off
so what I would have is that two shows
in a day right I have a school show in
the uh morning and a school show in the
afternoon and then so you'd have like
three hours four hours a kill and where
else you're gonna go as Ronald McDonald
but McDonald's right so we would go to a
McDonald's and we'd always get free
lunch right that was a given and you
never had to pay to kill time yeah I
also had an assistant too right so I had
a van that had a full down stage I had a
full-time assistant that set up my shoes
for me and you took care of my props
what this was supplied to you as per
McDonald's corporation you got an
assistant and a van
so so when you walk into a McDonald's to
kill timers Allen Iverson's autograph
one time no way yeah I dressed as an arm
yeah yeah he got the hook up wow yeah
and you walk into a McDonald's to kill
time and they're not expecting you
Incorporated and let them know how do
they know like did they know that you
were a Ronald they believed you or did
you just were they just like what a
great thing yeah are they like proved
that you're a Ronald and not some guy
yeah well I mean the suits looked really
good we're really good at what we did so
the minute we walked in they're like oh
[ __ ] Ronald's here this is great
yeah Black Wing and a mustache and it's
Ronald beneath that and they're like I
know yo I want to see Ronald go into it
a [ __ ] South Bronx McDonald's that's
a really funny sketch an Undercover Boss
Ronald McDonald yeah yeah
I just started here yeah yeah yeah
that's a funny thing so so what what do
you think about that mascot huh
really fun has any Ronald snapped yeah
have you ever seen a Ronald like lose it
Christina Ronald lose it no I haven't
seen a Ronald lose it
um
there's been like there's a there's so
Peter would Chase rattle around on
occasions somebody would get dressed up
in that cow suit and try to hit Ronald
with a with a pie so that was something
we always have to be on the lookout for
you
so so wait I have a question there's we
looked up and it said that there were
things that Ronald could never discuss
or could never disclose things about
McDonald's and if people asked he would
say talk to someone with regular shoes
what were some of those secrets that
wait you know that is that something you
said
yeah that was that was part of the
training right when you got asked a
question like you know a Beastie right
child obesity and they say are you
making kids fat they say hey you know
what that's a good question to ask
somebody with regular size shoes
[Music]
so that way it kind of kind of It kind
of it's usually kind of like some of
reporter that's trying to get an Expose
and trying to get get a quote from
Ronald the Press is chasing around the
Press is chasing the press and Peta yeah
depression you never would have thought
it yeah so do you have an ID card like
can you get do you get free McDonald's
for life
no no after I hung up the shoes I had to
pay for it just like everybody
but wait but wait when you had the shoes
he's not getting into like 4.99 they
wouldn't do that to you no never never I
mean he walked in like you owned the
place right and uh they let you do
whatever you want and that I never ever
had a problem walking to a McDonald's
and somebody was like you know you can't
do that right
hot days like you'll hang out in the
freezer no I just break it off
the code has the shoes ever cost in my
love interest yeah baby other shoes have
the shoes ever cost you a love interest
that's from that's from Mike that's a
question from the from our producers and
the shoes ever cost me a love interest
oh I got a better question
oh here we go I mean look have you ever
as Ronald
engage in intimacy
no no that just is uh that's that's not
my Kink man I don't want to I don't
wanna I wish he had said why didn't you
ask somebody with normal size shoes
somebody broke up with him and someone
have you ever broke up with someone did
it did being a Ronald ever get in the
way of a relationship
being around it probably stopped me from
like getting relationships right you
know I mean it's you know when you're
kind of at a bar meeting somebody like
well what do you do for a living and
it's like but I know I'm an accountant
or I'm a school teacher I was like well
I'm a circus clown right
right it's one of those ones that like
yeah right it's like saying yeah like
that's the thing how would you would you
would you like yeah would that deter
people were you embarrassed is what I'm
asking no I always liked what I did yeah
um yeah yeah it was I mean it was nobody
else had that job right yeah free
McDonald's I mean it's great I'm 37 and
I'm still telling people about my cousin
this is the fact that you have were
seven year full-time Ronald and we and
we this is mind-blowing time yeah all
right so so so
what how is it full time are you like
are they giving you every you would call
in and you get a schedule each week or
like did you real were you really used
five days a week or or was it just like
was it like you are on call and just
know that you're on call and it could be
four o'clock on a Thursday salary right
right right but yeah it's a salary but
were you working every day or
yeah it was you got a schedule right so
they would book shows in advance and you
know in a given month I'd probably work
like anywhere from 15 to 20 days in a
given month usually we're working on
Saturdays and Sundays a lot so you'd
have off during the week like Mondays
and Tuesdays but you do school shows
Monday through Friday
fairs and festivals on Saturdays and
Sundays you're basically a comic yeah
it's the same life
um yeah so amazing so do you know we are
a clown we are clowns yeah it's true do
you okay so let me ask you a question is
is it like I have clown in my blood it's
so funny dude yeah so all right so I
have a question okay is it like don't
you dare like there's a pay scale and
this is how it goes at McDonald's and
this is what the entry salary is or you
and AJ sitting there in clown makeup
while he's training you negotiating your
salary yeah no so yeah you actually get
paid by the locals the advertising
market so where where I was performing I
ended up working two different markets
but I gotta pay the salary right so
whether I worked or not I still got paid
there are other guys I also went
part-time after a while so as I was
getting out of being Ronald I went
part-time so I got paid per show but
there's a lot of guys that just get paid
per show and they're guaranteed like 200
shows a year and maybe it's 300 bucks a
show and so they're getting you know 60
grand for the year or something like
that wow
so so did you always do the same thing
for the seven years or did you like mix
it up or like
oh
the other year be at different School
shows and plus I have my own show that
it always you know was always evolving
and changing right my my strengths were
like juggling and unicycling and
acrobatics walking on my hands and stuff
like that but you wouldn't you wouldn't
just walk around on your hands as Ronald
yeah I would do that I would do those I
usually open my show I came out on stage
walking on my hands almost every time
I'm picturing you did you go to bed at a
local McDonald's though did you go to
the birthday parties oh no I mean yeah
no we didn't do birthday parties I mean
if we showed up and some kid was having
a birthday party but there wasn't but
there was when I was younger when you
had the birthday party Ronald would make
an appearance oh maybe that's just some
knockoff that was an employee of like
the kid in the back that does fries he's
like get in the costume walk out there
for a second maybe that could have that
could have been it yeah we really didn't
do a like a birthday party Alexa was
like like the owner operators kid and
they owned like 20 restaurants right
then we'd show up for that type of stuff
what about Benny's Health bunnies
oh yeah you got those too man Wheels
great benefits Blue Cross Blue Shield
wow
if you had surgery
from home and just you know got your
schedule and go away you go
that's it so there was nobody to report
to just like checking in with AJ
you had a local PR advertising agency
that typically like a union rep
ly
yeah that was AJ AJ was her basically so
like we had a local like advertised
market so like one side the average size
Market tried to schedule me to go do a
show at like uh what the heck was it it
was a restaurant right it was really
stupid I was like Hey McDonald's was
kind of like the only restaurant we can
go to is McDonald's they try to have us
go to a Cheesecake Factory for something
and they were adamant that I had to go
perform as Ronald at this Cheesecake
Factory and I put my foot my big foot
down and I said I can't do it and they
said yeah and I called AJ and AJ went
and called the agency and said yeah
Brian's not gonna go do that hell yeah
AJ yeah so they wanted you to go like
basically like like ransack a
what would you be doing at a Cheesecake
Factory they were doing a fundraiser for
the Ronald McDonald house so the
Cheesecake Factory is doing something
good for the Ronald McDonald House they
were hosting some event there so then
why were you not why didn't you want to
do it
because it was another restaurant and
that was just part of the rules right it
was like you know the list of things
that Ronald can't do going to another
restaurant is one of those things so you
basically deferred to the Constitution
thank you amazing unbelievable what
about Colin in sick
yeah what happened
just had to reschedule the show right
that was that was that big yeah that
would happen did you have to pay for
yourself
go ahead say again no please continue
yeah I was like you know it's not like
well it wasn't like we were doing
Mission critical work so if like Ronald
didn't show up somewhere I don't think
anybody was necessarily
right you just order chaos like
um did you have to buy your own
outfit
no the market paid for all that and that
got shipped to you that that and those
those were there was a company that made
the ones that were the quality level
that you had and that came directly from
the company and those were like real
deal outfits yep yep but then once
you're done you hang it up you don't
have access to that any longer right
well I'm not gonna say I don't have them
oh wow well they so they so they so you
were about to say about every three
months they give you a new shoot or
something yeah you got one basically
every you buy like you get like three to
start and then you know they've changed
the costumes over the years so every
time they've updated you get a new set
of suits uh but I've held on to a couple
of mine over the years and what about
the shoes are they like real deal clown
shoes or like the cheap ones that you
can get now like no they're made up they
use they take Doc Martens and they build
around a Doc Martin and so they're real
comfortable they're really nice that is
a huge information that is genius I
wonder if Doc Martin knows that they're
the basis of the McDonald's shoe call
them up yeah my other cousin
oh wow so okay wow and and and and and
and so have you hung up the boots since
you hung up the shoes
have you ever gotten dressed again and
if so what was the occasion for you ever
throw it on you ever throw it on at a
party in your own home
so once I literally lost a bet and the
BET was if I lost I had to come to work
dressed as Ronald McDonald
and I did
wow okay so as luck would have it so I
this podcast my name is Sally you told
me that we do a podcast called taste
buds and we argue about food and stuff
like that and the other comic that's not
here today Joe is obsessed uh with
McDonald's and he lost the first season
of this this podcast and as a uh
punishment he owns a bar in the Lower
East Side of Manhattan we're gonna have
him go into work in bartend dressed as
Ronald
cool so basically what happened to you
now I'm not gonna step on any toasty do
you have a way for us do you have any
ends where I can somehow get my hands on
it I'm not saying it's yours and we'll
we'll dry clean it and overnight it back
I'm not saying that you you could do
that I don't want to break any code I
don't want to put your number but can
you at least lead us to where we want to
do it so that it is as real to life and
over the top as possible as Ian said and
so we don't want to just do that like
you know generic clown in a bag from
like Party City and it's like no this is
like the real deal Holyfield of uh we
want him to look like as good is there a
can you lead us
to a path on how to get like a really
good uniform or costume I should say
yeah there's probably ways we can
probably figure that out
um yeah my boy is a wicked smile like
let's figure some stuff out for you okay
this is I can't believe what is going on
this this unfolded today
I can't believe it he came here from JFK
I came here from Austin from JFK to here
to bring you this gift this is
unbelievable did you ever have to take a
[ __ ] in the middle of a middle of a show
because as a comic if we're on stage in
that house oh yeah I don't eat before I
go on what were some of your Ronald
rituals I mean and I'm being serious not
facetious but like are the people that
he mentored and that you had a
relationship with him over the course of
years like was there any morning
gathering for him
yeah we're still waiting to put the
memorial service like I mean the guy was
beloved and he worked with you know he
was friends with Penn teller Lance
Burton so that mean he was well known
inside like kind of the circus a magic
world so okay there's gonna be a funeral
out in L.A and all the Ramos are talking
about going and we're trying to figure
out like hey what do we we also have
like the striped socks issues so we're
thinking about hey baby we we've been
honor of AJ at least to wear the socks
maybe wear the shoes throw up all the
guys oh that's so nice yeah he was he
was absolutely beloved like you know my
whole way he changed he changed the
entire trajectory of my life right
oh my God
this is unbelievable what a great man
what I appreciate you taking the time to
tell us all this I could I could
literally ask you another hour I mean
this is insane that's insane you ever go
on a on a bender with other other
Ronalds
oh well the conventions you know the
conventions every two years and you know
we would we would have a good time you
got to let us some steam yeah oh wow
yeah it was uh you know these guys were
your brothers too right so I mean these
are guys that he has so much in common
with and who else you got to talk to
about being Ronald right it's not like
you can dude he's a comic yes that's
what it is yeah you literally there's so
many parallels it's unbelievable you
should get them on Zoom yeah so you get
a hundred of us together that are all
like they're funny they're talented
they're really good performers and it's
just like
yeah it's just like joke after joke
trick after trick and then you know we
go out we have a good time we'll take
over a bar you know the next thing you
know people are like doing handstands on
chairs or juggling bottles oh my God
that is amazing I have to I have to go I
want to party I know we want to party
with the Ronalds is there a way we could
do a contest can you invite us yeah to
the next time you party with Ronald's
and we'll come and we'll we'll promote
it or something I don't know
well we haven't gotten together for
years man we all got fired so we got
fired well they kind of you know they
can't still have the character but no
there is there's you don't see Ronald
around anymore right so the program yeah
why is that Brian why is that
well I think McDonald's basically saw
like Joe Camel and you know the
advertising the kids just became
something that was just not something
that they wanted to deal with anymore so
it's still it's still a good character
for like the Ronald McDonald House and
still makes appearances for that but
they really this is so disassociated
restaurant from the character pretty
much oh wow yeah you're right you don't
see them in photos there yeah
once in a while you know where I'll see
him once in a while I'll see you in your
dreams what's that
yeah I'll see that like uh fiberglass
one of him sitting on a bench
yeah yeah that's basically it right and
it's you know they're just there because
of like the one feels like moving it
probably wow you're right yeah I didn't
even realize that
how many kids Joy now because
everybody's effects so many kids
diabetes Well you know [ __ ] happens yeah
that's the Box knows that was probably
the big thing right they just kept
getting you know nailed on the
advertising the kids and McDonald's said
let's not get accused of that anymore
and that was kind of the end of the
character
how do you how and how do you approach
is it AJ that you have to approach for a
wage are you getting a performance
review
a raise local market yeah you work with
the local market so like like you're in
New York so there's like a New York New
Jersey
um Nick Copco type of like McDonald's
it's like a Consortium of all the owner
operators plus the corporate stores and
they pull money together to do like
local advertising
um in local events and stuff like that
and so the Ronald budget would come out
of the local McDonald's Co-op budget and
so when you got paid you got paid
through the co-op and so when you go
like ask for a raise and stuff like that
you're going to the co-op not
necessarily AJ they would try to make it
Equitable so in general folks got paid
generally the same from Market to Market
but you dealt directly with the with the
uh with the with the co-op to uh for
your salary and benefits and stuff like
that did you buy your own makeup
no no it was really nice man I don't
have to pay for anything right they
provided the van which is great you know
paid for all the gas and repairs they'd
buy all the makeup all the crops yeah so
did you did you did you have the van on
you in your regular like the van stayed
with you at your home
yeah so I had a place to park it
um and so I had a buddy of mine had a um
a truck repair shop and he had a fenced
in because you got the big thing you
worry about the van getting vandalized
oh because it's identifiable yeah oh
yeah yeah it was all decorated out with
McDonald's and stuff like that so so I
had a friend of mine who let me park my
van over on his lot he kept it locked up
and gave me a key to his fence so you
could never just in a in a pinch you
could never use the Ronald van for your
own personal needs no I mean it just
wasn't worth it right I mean it was it
was a show van right so it's not like I
could like carry like cement or like a
whole bunch of plywood in it right
inside there was like it was a generator
there's a dressing room oh wow wow the
stage would fold down off of the
hydraulic stage I'd fall down oh no so
the the van actually became the stage
yeah yeah that is that is that is
involved that is like that they sunk a
lot of money into that
yeah I tell you that the 90s for Ronald
was like the golden years man we were
doing stuff like we did stuff with the
Rockettes I got the I get to go to
football games I mean Ronald is really
it was it was it was cool derama back in
the 90s yeah let me let me flip the
question that you asked earlier did you
ever get laid because you were Ronald
uh uh I doubt that
I doubt that you ever come home and you
were just so goddamn tired and you just
went to bed with it all on
yeah because you wake up and you got
freaking
looks like uh was the the shroud of
Jesus
[Laughter]
drive home as Ronald
well I had an assistant so they would
take me back but I would take the makeup
off so it was kind of kind of
interesting right because you do the
show and while you're out there and
everybody goes wrong right there you
shout out your name you're very famous
then you go into your dress and you get
change and come out and then you're just
normal you're anonymous right so like
when you do your show you're still South
you're so on stage in your cell All
Stage so you can stop all the time right
you know hey so I love you on a
practical show cause yeah yeah right
yeah I walk around nobody knows who I am
so wow so that's actually the best did
you ever get drunk and pull the Ronald
card like do you know who the [ __ ] I am
[Laughter]
you must have gotten free drinks at bars
I I just think you know when you're out
I never really talked too much about it
I say I was a circus clown but I never
really told people I was Ronald McDonald
what made you get out of it
what's that
say again what'd you just say when I was
wrong with I never talked about being
Ronald but now that I'm not now I'm
decided you know on the apparently I'm
going to be a podcast exposing the whole
program to everybody
[Laughter]
it's unbelievable this was amazing uh
thank you for I would stay on with you I
don't want to keep you any longer but we
also are out of time here but dude I
mean yeah Ian I'm showing up I mean for
you to answer the call and then take
your time and then just give us all this
this couldn't have been better we got
the Straight From the Source we got
every and I am so glad this happened and
DeRosa was
unbelievable dude we'd love to have you
on another time if you can if you can
work with us and somehow obtaining a
costume that that would be amazing
whether we buy it uh order from some
place borrow it from you no pressure but
um thank you so so much
yeah man my pleasure I I feel like I'm
coming away from this
having so much more education it was
great I I now know this people don't
know this stuff no it's great
conversation some people don't even know
that Ronald McDonald was a guy yeah yeah
why would you know you we gotta keep the
memory alive yeah we're carrying the
torch well God bless AJ for all the good
work he did Brian thank you for your
time I'm gonna hand you back to Ian I'd
love to I I'd love to write questions
down that I didn't today and get you
back on sometime because there's no
shortage of questions
all right man I'll I'll see if I can get
some other guys to answer some questions
for you too
oh yeah Round Table discussion oh my God
Round Table discussion develop that yeah
Ronnie's Round Table wow all right uh
thank you brother so much
clowns in the rounds
hey
the man dude thank you so much
I think you know we end this episode in
honor of AJ which is some nice reviews
people left him over the years and I
guess
I guess those other let's just say but
we did let's just do the worst for the
one right
what do you want to do because we don't
have time to do the other two worst
right now of course no not at all maybe
we've forced DeRosa to do them yeah okay
at the top of it we haven't we haven't
pulled out so we haven't pulled out
maybe we just forced to Rosa yeah at the
top of it guys look you saw this episode
unfold okay first of all Ian he always
delivers we're having so much fun we
only got to the first of the three
Lightnings and we are out of time so we
didn't want to do this to you but I
think I made the right decision that we
made the right decision because we
followed that story which I hoping that
you guys listening wanted to ask every
question that I want to and we four
we're four going the other two lightning
we'll have to have you back for this
yeah yes I'd love to have you back if I
could do another episode right now I
would but I have it was amazing it was
great we just go out with some nice
memories of AJ let's go out with some
nice memories uh let's let's read his
quotes this is this is what people said
about AJ you worked the magic that made
our weekend retreat a success the
make-a-wisha foundation enjoyed the the
message and the magic President Bill
Clinton
[Music]
[Laughter]
be the next one
oh you were the best I thank you Queen
Noor of Jordan oh my God yo 80s got the
Heavy Hitters though
Jordan Illuminati I love Jordan the best
that we have ever seen McDonald's
Corporation wow the event was a colossal
success due in no small part to your
presence who's that from oh just the
international clown Hall of Fame thank
you very much thank you I have many
requests for you to return Northwestern
University I am also a robot
aye Northwestern University
oh God here we go okay our office was
deluged with notes in email regarding
your outstanding performance they've
specifically commented on your
involvement with the audience high
energy and engaging stories when they
come to one of my shows at a reason
Gathering many were still talking about
your magic you were the master schmoozer
tbg trade show and event marketing and
management I have never gotten reviews
like this for my own stuff I mean this
guy's a god he's a God uh guys poor
little orange drink out for him yeah uh
yeah poor McFlurry on the ground for AJ
he looks like a character that's amazing
uh
podcast dates anything you want to plug
yes
uh Being Ian
is out I'm loving it I'm loving it
McDonald's oh my God I didn't even
realize I didn't mean it I saw that you
did not mean that you didn't mean it
patreon.com beanie and pod BNN on
YouTube
[Music]
and I'll be on the Pod soon yes yes it's
gonna be so fun and uh yeah Being Ian uh
real good time on iTunes Spotify YouTube
patreon so did the patreon we got a lot
of fun things going on and uh I am uh
gonna be headlining stand up live
Phoenix Arizona Bray Improv San Jose
Improv Pittsburgh improv uh come on out
punchline Philly busy busy busy
ianfidance.com I animal69 Instagram
twitch and Twitter I love it if you if
you aren't on the Ian train you gotta
get on it the funniest dude in the world
choo choo um what else uh if you want to
support the Pod easy way to support it
guys just subscribe to the no press
Channel on YouTube uh leave us a rating
on iTunes follow us on Spotify any of
those things help do them all if you
love us easy way to support we have our
merch up it's on our website savocano
comedy.com it's on jodarozainfo.com I
got solo stuff we got group stuff uh my
tour dates are uh for the fall roll up
I'm gonna be touring in October November
and December Florida California Atlanta
Alabama Knoxville Toronto for the first
time Hamilton Canada uh I'm all over the
place guys Evansville uh Louisville
anyway saddlecountercomedy.com they're
all up right now they're all on sale
right now we added second shows in Tampa
Atlanta Toronto and somewhere else that
I'm forgetting
um and Joda Rosa has dates too Joe
torosainfo.com he's throwing they're all
up there and go down and see Joey Rose's
174 Rivington one it's in Rivington
Street in the Lower East Side best
sandwiches great Dive Bar good
atmosphere
174 Remington and uh go there if you
want to see it Ronald is actually we won
the one because it was the worst was the
glasses right so I say to you I still
love you babe and I still love you
always have always will they come into
the mic